Speaker 1: I have an unbelievable clip for you
today. Donald Trump was interviewed yesterday by
Fox News propagandist Maria Bartiromo, who has
gone from being a pretty good and respectable
finance and economic journalist 15 years ago,
20 years ago to being a Trump brown noser on Fox
News, the ultimate Trump brown noser allowing
unhinged conspiracy theories to be spread on
her programs over the last year. Maria Bartiromo
interviewed Donald Trump, and it might not shock
you to hear that Donald Trump now says the
Ukrainians are only even putting up a fight
thanks to the weapons I gave them. Now you might
hear that and say, Where David, sir? Aren't those
the weapons he delayed giving to Ukraine because
he wanted dirt on Biden? And the answer is yes,
it is exactly those weapons. But Donald Trump,
in the period of eight days has gone from Putin,
is savvy, genius and smart for what he's doing
with Ukraine taking great property in Ukraine
to actually Putin's not good. This
wouldn't have happened under a well,
he didn't say Putin is not good at it, he said.
This wouldn't have happened under my watch
to now saying Ukraine should be thanking me that
they're even putting up a fight because they're
using the weapons I gave them. Listen to this
delusional 180, by the way. The translation here,
the five second version of this clip is me,
me, me, me, me, me, me. That's that. That's the
Speaker 3: summary. Good. Now, Russia has gotten
in deeper than they ever thought possible,
so they would, frankly, I think they probably
would be right now in a good position to do
something worth. I think they're in much deeper
than they thought. To a certain extent, because
of the weapons that I gave and that the Ukrainians
used so well, I mean, they used so, well, amazing.
I think Russia is something could be done with
them right now because they're not they're not
making it look, but they are looking. Well, they
have to. You have to work out a deal. They have
to stop killing these people. They're killing
all these people and they have to stop it and
they have to stop it now. But they don't respect
the United States and the United States is like,
I don't know. They are doing anything about it.
Speaker 1: So these are really inspirational
foreign policy assessments from Donald Trump.
So, yes, Trump is saying thanks to the weapons I
initially withheld while I attempted to. Extort
Zelensky, OK, that's that's what he's. That's
the translation here. Thanks to those weapons I
originally withheld for the extortion attempted,
but was ultimately sort of pressured into giving
Ukraine because things blew up and Alexander
Vindman testified and all that stuff. Thanks to
those weapons, Ukraine now is to some degree,
resisting Russian aggression. It is out of
this world, guys, completely out of this world.
He withheld military aid because he wanted
Zelensky to get them debt dirt on Joe Biden.
Open an investigation and then the whistle
was blown. It wasn't a perfect phone call.
He released the aid. He got impeached. On and on
and on. And had it not blown up in his face. I
mean, really understand. Understand the scope
of that when we go back and we remember, OK.
He withheld the aid. But then he gave it
to them, but why did he give it to them?
He gave it to them because things exploded and
people found out about what he was doing. Had
Vindman not blown the whistle, had everything
that happened, not happened. Ukraine would not
likely have gotten those weapons, or certainly
not in any kind of reasonable amount of time. And
so thanks to the people who blew the whistle
over what Trump was doing to extort Ukraine,
Ukraine got some of those weapons. And of course,
it's also extraordinarily self-centered because
the truth is, Ukraine now has received
weapons and military aid from countries
all over the world and additionally from the Biden
administration. So even even taken at its face,
what Trump is saying is absurd, but everything
somehow is about him. Putin was so scared of
them that he didn't do this while Trump
was president. The weapons that Ukraine is
fighting with are thanks to Trump. Everything
is Trump. It's me, me, me. And unfortunately,
if you look at interviews with Trumpists,
many of them have fallen for this stuff.